what up space fam golsan here from anime
uproar back at it again to discuss the
latest crazy developments with demon
slayer we got season two's exact date
confirmed and all the season details we
got a new trailer to discuss that shows
way more than any previous trailer for
season 2 and we got as usual an update
on demon slayers insane manga and box
office sales so definitely stay tuned
for this one if you do enjoy seeing
these demon slayer updates then channel
the tangero with it and smash that like
button we all know smashing his tundra
energy and passing is demon king of pop
energy so choose wisely if you haven't
make this the video you subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications or you
will miss future demonstrator video
updates about this and all upcoming
seasons and news and while you wait for
the anime season to come out feel free
to check out my growing demonstrator
playlist that includes videos on all
demon slayers breath styles hashira
demon moons and much much more link to
that is in the description and now
without further ado let's jump into it
first the most updated manga sales
number as of making this video
demonstrate has sold about 150 million
manga copies it has not only cracked the
top 10 best-selling manga series of all
time it's currently in 9th place and
will no doubt continue to climb with the
upcoming season 2 hype especially since
it's already so close to the number 8
spot keep in mind demonstrators started
in 2016 while all the others in the top
10 started in the 1900s making demon
slayer's achievement in the past few
years all the more impressive and
frankly just straight up insane not only
did it come out way later and so has had
less time to pile up the sales it also
has averaged a much higher sales per
volume number than every other top 10
manga except for blackjack which is
ahead for now though blackjack it must
be noted has been around since 1973. for
instance demon slayer has averaged so
far
6.52 million average sales per volume
while dragon ball has averaged 6.19
million one piece has averaged 4.9
million and naruto has averaged 3.47
million you know we love all these manga
series on this channel but just want to
put it in perspective how much
demonstrator has accomplished and how
fast with only 23 volumes now quickly
with an update of the demonstra mugen
train movie it was not only the
best-selling movie of 2020 worldwide it
is also the best-selling movie ever in
japanese box office history with
40.32 billion japanese yen growth so far
compared to second place spirited aways
31.68 billion third place titanic's
26.20 billion and fourth place frozen's
25.48 billion so in a way demonstrator's
box office numbers are even crazier than
the manga sales because it not only beat
all other anime and manga inspired films
but it even beat all non-anime films too
so with all this in mind let's turn to
the much awaited season 2 and everything
we know about it demonstrator season 2
will be streaming on funimation in the
us canada the uk ireland australia and
new zealand on sunday october 10th 2021
so we are only about two weeks away
which is amazing news cnet also reports
that it will be available on hulu and
crunchyroll in addition to funimation as
well i know a bunch of you asked if it
was going to be on crunchyroll so it
looks like you will be able to catch it
there too with the first episode
starting on the 10th of october there
were some questions about whether the
moog and train movie parts would be
covered in this season or if it would
start with the entertainment district
arc and i said before that i was cool
with either result well now we know that
the first part of the anime season will
be covering the mugen train arc which
honestly is not a bad thing it makes
sense and otherwise anime season only
watchers would have no idea what's going
on the film will be adapted into a 7
episode arc and this should not be a
problem for hardcore fans especially
since we'll be getting 70 new scenes new
music tracks a new theme song and a
never-before-seen original episode of
kyojo rengoku i don't know about you but
i can't get enough of rengoku thus yeah
we'll have to wait for the entertainment
district arc but i'm hyped we'll get new
scenes and a completely new episode
since it'll all be adding to the
demonstrator world we love so much after
all if you want straight manga chapters
you always have the finished manga at
your disposal so now you're probably
wondering when will the brand new
entertainment district arc episodes
start specifically well it'll start on
sunday december 5th 2021 and according
to cnet we'll be getting half a year's
worth of sword slashing action which i'm
psyched to see this october will
definitely be a big month for demons
there with the dropping of the anime the
game on october 16th and the
demonstrator box that was supposed to be
released on october 5th but now on
amazon.ca at least it has been shifted
to november 9th which might be for the
best giving the enemy a chance to hype
it up a bit more before its inevitable
release that will definitely greatly
help manga sales there are definitely
people like me who have been
specifically waiting for the box set so
we can get all the volumes in one go and
even bonus material i'm a bit salty
they'll have to wait longer than i
thought but it's okay i'll live with it
i'll manage as you can tell i have
pre-ordered the box set and when it does
come i will update you guys on all the
bonus content so if you want to see that
just follow anime upper on instagram
anime uproar there is already and will
be plenty more demonstrate content on
there for you lastly i will mention the
latest trailer and all the new parts we
got to see from the entertainment
district arc and this has definitely
been the best trailer released so far
i'll link the trailer in the description
and the entertainment district arc
specifically starts around 4 minutes and
30 seconds we get to see more shots of
the district and we get to see tangent
and his amazing and unique demon slayer
blades which are dual nichiren cleavers
that shine a beautiful yellow on the
blade's edges we also see how buff
tengan is you see his veins bulging on
his huge arms if you do want all the
spoilers about tangent and his powers
explained definitely make sure to check
out my house strongest tangent uzui
video where i explain it all in detail
and rank him among the other hasher in
terms of strength we see a quick shot of
three female ninja looking very fine and
i don't think it's a big spoiler to
point out who they are but if you are
extra sensitive click away now i will be
getting into some spoiler-esque
territory in three
two
one
so these are actually tangents three
wives and they do serve a significant
role in this arc i don't have to mention
how jealous zenitsu is when he hears
tengen has not won but three beautiful
wives the animation is no doubt
beautiful in this trailer and the
trailer is jumping from tengen to his
wives and then back to tangent
suggesting how concerned he is over them
and this arc is in fact about getting
them back so it totally makes sense that
the trailer would spend time on them we
then also see upper moon 6 doki who is
definitely one of the prettiest manga
characters and from the trailer it does
look like they may well do her beauty
justice we see zaintsu looking worried
and inosuke breaking through a wall in
the entertainment district nothing
surprising there but it's great to see
these two nonetheless we then get more
shots of doki which makes sense because
she is a major antagonist of this arc we
actually get a shot of her in action
attacking tundra which i haven't seen
animated before this trailer she uses
her ribbons to attack and propel her
while tundra blocks it with his sword
the eruption of color is beautiful to
see and you see the donkey's demon
aesthetic and wardrobe is perfect for
the entertainment district arc we see
nesgo too showing that she will be a
part of this fight and arc if you don't
know nezuko is going to have some big
moments in this one including a new
amazing form and i've been waiting to
see it animated for a long time so can't
wait for that we are shown tanjiro using
dance of the fire god so we'll get to
see that breath style evolve and that is
it pretty much everything we can hope to
see in a trailer at this point we got
fighting more shots of daki more shots
of tankit and of course all of our main
characters but it also left a bunch of
stuff out which will be a great treat
for fans when they actually see them in
the anime i mentioned ezco's new form
and we will also see a stronger demon
than daki who hasn't been shown yet so
the trailer even though it showed more
than before left plenty out as well even
me who has read the entire manga is so
hyped to see how some of this stuff is
going to look animated and that is
pretty much it for this video an update
on manga sales film sales the release
date and structure of the new season and
the breakdown of the new trailer that
really blew this arc open in a way that
previous trailers for the season haven't
so far let me know what you're most
looking forward to seeing animated in
this upcoming arc as you probably
guessed i gotta go with nezuko's new
form personally i think it's gonna be
straightfire if you did enjoy this
update video and want to keep the demon
slayer updates coming then channel the
tundra within and smash that like button
we all know smashing is tundra energy
and passing is demon king of pop energy
so choose wisely if you haven't make
this the video you subscribe and this is
crucial hit that notification bell to
turn on all notifications so you don't
miss any future demonstrator updates and
videos about this and all upcoming
seasons and news so yeah if you don't
want to miss any demonstrator updates
that's definitely the best thing to do
just hit that subscribe button and while
you wait for the anime season to come
out feel free to check out my growing
demonstrator playlist that includes
videos on all demon slayers breath
styles hashira demon moons and much much
more link to that playlist is in the
description and if you're cruising
through the playlist and see that i
haven't covered a video you're dying to
see let me know what it is in the
comments and it may be the next
demonstrator video you see and until
next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you